my parents were groomed and manipulated
for two and a half years this family was
they were our best friends he was our
best friend what do you want to say to
the public who maybe like me right
we're saying out loud are you kidding me
why didn't these parents do more they
would have done more if they had seen
more two and a half years to build
ultimate trust with individual members
of a family is something that happened
slowly but it happens because you're
frequently with those people at the 70s
they don't know what a pedophile is so
there is some naivety there but my
parents weren't stupid you have to
imagine the person that you would sign
paperwork to say if I die you take care
of my kids that's how close we were to
this family so first of all people don't
want to believe that they aren't seeing
something that's in their own family or
in their own congregation or in their
own neighborhood but that's because we
have a bias the person we trust in love
we're not gonna see the the little
subtle warning signs because we don't
want to first of all so that's really
the crux of that story I even talked to
my mother about it and she said at the
end of the day there's no time I would
ever let you go as a 12 year old girl
somewhere with a 40 year old man it just
wouldn't happen you don't have an uncle
or somebody different see that's what
I'm saying it's not different that's
what people want to believe that this is
different it is not different this is
the person that you trust most who's
become like your second father it is not
some out-of-the-blue thing the favorite
uncle the favorite school teacher the
favorite guy at church that you're doing
the service projects with the favorite
the favorite the favorite and that's who
this guy was
your dad has since passed away since the
filming of this documentary what do you
think he would make of all of this my
dad was such a good man and he he was so
embarrassed that we never thought that
he would talk about it on camera because
it was just that one experience but then
of course Berchtold accused him of many
other
things and I think he took the guilt and
shame of that to his grave because you
know you can see it on his face during
the document yeah I could see that it
was dads
take it on they're supposed to protect
their little girls he didn't see it I
don't think he ever fully forgave
himself even though I worked really hard
and tried to help him see you were a you
were groomed and manipulated too I have
to just say I'm kind of glad that he I
mean he had bone cancer we didn't want
him to suffer anyway but it would have
been hard on him you know to have all of
the you know the the negative parts but
at the same time he said when we went
and saw the documentary and and you know
a lot of his friends and family were
there and he said you know I'm I'm ready
because if my part can help somebody
else avoid doing something stupid and
maybe that will save their child's life
they don't even know it yet but it might
then I'm okay with it and my mom was the
same way she went back to school after
all of us graduated and became a social
worker at least hundreds of kids in
foster care good foster homes and
adoptive homes and lobbied before
Congress to get funding to open a Center
for Missing and Exploited Children in
Idaho and in Utah so my mom and dad
worked really hard to try to make up for
their their indiscretion you know that
and not seeing what they eventually of
course they saw but they were sick and
brokenhearted do they understand why the
public's reaction oh they do they do
yeah they do because they've you know I
was such an idiot or I was so stupid or
why couldn't we have seen or why didn't
we protect her and know so that she
wouldn't have had to go through that
yeah there my mom and dad and if I had
not had 12 amazing childhood years
before I woke up in the back of that
motor home where we ate dinner together
every night we talked we were
unconditionally loved we were listened
to they communicated when people say
what do I do and like sit down every day
around the dinner table and eat dinner
with your kids with no electronics
that's what you do first of all so that
you build that relationship in that
Kayson